yeah boys welcome to the very first
stream hopefully working yeah is welcome
softeners I don't I don't we couldn't
afford jacksepticeye so we have Brad
here I regret this sausage roll is like
I get to break in the British it's
hundred percent British no one else does
it
cuz Marty had never heard of a sausage
roll ever but like everyone in this
country knows what sausage roll is it's
very like famous yeah and you didn't
what just happened what the hell was
that
Thank You Hannah tryna [ __ ] can you
move on you can just see it looks
disgusting alright ready
I want you to it okay mmm so good ah
it's even better with the sort of sexual
overtime and I do drone wars robot war
activate so what is framework because
you invert this and didn't tell me I
thank you like almost everything you do
shut up please
we have our droning they're gonna fight
all right this is four points okay very
serious how do we make them fight
that's a good question cuz we have here
oh my god where we can modify we got
spray paint we got I don't know how this
will help fighting you know this might
not be approved by twitch but we have
weapons as well so that we can modify
the most powerful unique most advanced
technology known to man a plastic fork
if you're going to go right into them as
I I'm gonna have a pilot come on yeah
good luck with that you're gonna lose I
always watch his twitch montages where
people get like big donations and they
like oh my god
where did you get that I've saved it huh
what did you do I think I activated the
new new activation you got a new shot
all right Chad which one do you think is
gonna win comment down below you place
your bets
Jeff gold them or Channing Tatum Oh Jeff
yeah Jeff wait wait don't know why is he
doing that
why is it doing that ah no don't snot to
watch TV either that's too expensive
orchestral image is something cheap a
meter something cheap ha ha ha anything
with the camera
Jim yeah yeah that's right boy [ __ ] you
Jeff Goldblum I mean Channing Tatum oh
no oh yeah sorry time with you that's
top ha ha ha ha
now there's a random person in this
wheel all right we don't know who know
we didn't make these we're going to pick
around a person then we're going to pick
a random topic we want everyone who's
watching the stream right now this is
extremely important whatever happens in
the world right now doesn't matter we
need to do this we need everyone to
tweet this person this topic for example
Kanye West giraffe all right a good
example don't do it
and it's for a noble cause our
entertainment yes okay why don't you
massage spin it
can we get some bingo music going on
here keep spinning
no no no no no he's gonna break it keep
spinning
he would normally be this side of the
person and he does this little time all
he does is that and then you interview
someone for about two seconds who is
that
my Tino's Jimmy Fallon Jimmy pow
Jimmy Fallon a felon you're about to get
the sweet love a Twitter rule and hold
your horses we don't know what we don't
know what to tweet we're gonna tweet on
Mac oh it fell out right away oh my god
it fell out right away alright are we
ready
it's not funny it came funny because
it's such a weird Memphis hang gliding
hang gliding Jimmy Fallon find a picture
of hang gliding tweeted to Jimmy Fallon
brother mornin to you lady what's your
favorite color green your favorite color
is green did you know that's my pubes
are green yeah they're laying right here
actually what the [ __ ] so the motor half
replace them on Jack where they belong
that's correct
a weird fact I've seen jacksepticeye's
dude it's really weird
yeah genuine nice in a Big Pig do you
have your dress on I think people want
to see that well here's the thing maybe
we should do
secret reveal weighed 3,000 but wait is
that my that's my donation take it I
take it up take it up take it up take it
up take it up big vehicles around which
is why washing with pulling tiny little
oh no no they're doing further working
with my nipples allow ah which means the
bra is ineffective of what the reason
I'm wearing the rock yeah boy that
covers right yeah yeah there this is so
weird I never been too scared in my life
you yeah I'm just getting naked I like
it this is what I want you looks so
weird this is so weird like what are we
doing here why are we still here all
right there we go so difficult
okay I think we're way past ten minutes
now so can we speed up the margin damn
girl you look good
better socks and sandals but is it
really bad I can both I can I can argue
I mean what do you want argue for I'm
Way less like liable for like everything
I say I think it sucks and tentative
fine oh you just all right I'll vote
against yes and sandals I don't see the
big deal all right
if I want to wear something said I
actually do it you got a problem with
that and you pick on me for being an old
man and this is actually what you do
might say you like when I wear the taco
bell's right well maybe she did now she
did she didn't shitty no well there you
go
my argument is that the whole point of
like wearing nice clothes to appeal to
might say why you never tell me this
yeah she said I don't like his slippers
in general by the way I don't know how
bad the sound the white hot I think I
win and I didn't say a word
[Laughter]
this one comes from Barry from Scotland
Barry from Scotland do the accent we did
all right
RRR Barry from a pirate ship uh where
can I find the most top quality of means
our Barry I'm very from Scotland a good
fire uh well I don't know there's this
fresh new meme called like it's from the
movie 28 Jump Street tell me the name
I've never heard of this one so there's
just one part where Channing Tatum has
to pretend that he's Mexican all right
so he says my name is Jeff all right
really everyone is talking about I just
don't want to do when we put it off the
mall can we put on some romantic music
give me my phone throw it again
don't throw one we can't put on my my
name you know like Curb Your Enthusiasm
[Music]
it's like one of us aside we are this is
it this is basically thank you for
watching
thank you the word day the best club I
will see you guys next week
then can we cut this right as we kiss
very about the kid you like you spot on
my hand stop coming out you're not gonna
pee myself I got a P so back this is the
what how do you do this I said how do
you kiss it
my mighty rose look at me sounds like a
mud yeah no look at me look at me Jeremy
I got another confession to make
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
look at me look at me
ah listen accessor sorry laughs yeah